[Musik]
lügen haben kurze beine und enorm hohe
klickzahlen gerade in den digitalen
medien hat sich eine ganze industrie der
gezielten manipulation gebildet der
philosoph vincent fälle hendrix leitet
an der universität kopenhagen das
weltweit einzige institut für babbel
studies und erforscht tabla sind ebenso
wie fake news heute erfahren wir warum
solche phänomene unsere demokratie
bedrohen und was wir ganz konkret
dagegen tun können
herzlich willkommen hendricks was war
denn die fake news über die sich sie
sich diese woche am meisten geärgert
haben und wie haben sie davon erfahren
da wir schon mal in der sternstunde
philosophie sind wollen wir uns an die
philosophie halten
donald trump ständiges hin und her
lavieren mit den fakten in den news wenn
die news für ihn sprechen vertraute
ihnen und wenn sie gegen ihn sind
dahinter steckt eine art denkt prinzip
wenn die fakten für sich sprechen
akzeptierst du sie wenn sie gegen die
sprechen sind sie fällt nix so sagte
auch die ehemalige sprecher des weißen
hauses chance besser wenn er im weißen
haus auftrag sehr oft wie er vom
waisenhaus sind mit den fakten nicht
einverstanden
wie kann man mit fakten nicht
einverstanden sein ohne falsch zu liegen
aristoteles würde sich zweimal in seinem
grab umdrehen wenn er das hören würde
sein satz vom ausgeschlossenen
widerspruch wenn also donald trump hin
und her laviert ob er das was er sagt er
gesagt hat oder nicht wie seine
behauptungen kürzlich zum ereignis in
charlottesville als wir zuerst sagte ich
werde niemanden beschuldigen um es
später doch zu tun und kommt dann darauf
zurück in dem er behauptet die medien
hätten falsch berichtet als sie sagten
er sei gegen die weißen rassisten und
die nazis
also es ist nicht nur eine einzelne
meldung die sie derzeit besorgt sondern
ein ganzes strategie des umgangs mit
nachrichten wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe
donald trump ist sicher das gesicht
dieser taktik aber es ist ja eine ganze
phänomen reihe die die westliche welt an
sich betrifft
ja sicher man kann sagen genau um das
geht es beim populismus
populismus ist keine politische
ideologie sondern eine strategie es gibt
sowohl linken wie rechten populismus
sein leben spricht man von rechten
populismus trump ist rechts
ausgerichteter populismus aber hugo
chavez war linker populismus
es ist also weniger eine ideologie als
eine strategie bei der man eine klar
definierte person oder gruppe als gegner
deklariert es ist also sie gegen uns ob
wir brüssel heißt washington der rast
welt in den usa die armen die reichen
usw
der grund weshalb das so gut
funktioniert ist das mein problem nur
eine einzige ursache hat und ich kann
auf meine gegner zeigen sie sind das
problem
so gibt es ein eindeutiges narrativ wir
kriegen sie das ist populismus
es gibt also eine verbindung bin ich sie
richtig verstehe zwischen fake news und
populismus da werden wir noch darauf
eingehen die eine sache aber scheint
doch klar zu sein
fake news wenn wir darüber sprechen gibt
es glaube ich zwei schulen die eine
können wir sagen ist die zynische schule
und die sagt nur es ist überhaupt nichts
neues das gab es schon immer das ist das
klima unserer meinungsbildung da wo ist
mir gar nicht so besorgt sein die andere
nennen wir sie mal die alarmistische
schule sagt es ist ganz etwas anderes
unter digitalen bedingungen man kann das
mit nichts vergleichen was wir früher
haben welcher schule gehören sie an
ich gehöre wahrscheinlich zum lager sagt
fake news ist nichts neues
vermutlich gibt es sie seit es uns
menschen gibt bestimmt aber seit wir
zeitungen und damit auch news haben
problematisch an den fake news ist nicht
dass sie neu sind sondern die art wie
sie heute konstruiert werden fake news
sind in der regel nicht einfach falsche
informationen wahrheit und unwahrheit
werden miteinander zu einem ganzen
vermischt und dann so in umlauf gebracht
dass man jene trifft die man treffen
will sie die zielgruppe
je nachdem pro oder contra zudem sind
fake news meist sehr laut sie machen so
viel lärm und sind so spektakulär dass
nicht einmal mainstream medien
stehen können sie aufzunehmen und
ihrerseits in umlauf zu bringen weshalb
weil das wichtigste gut in den
onlinemedien und dem
informationszeitalter aufmerksamkeit ist
sie ist das wertvollste überhaupt und
wie gewinnt man aufmerksamkeit der
nobelpreisträger höhere zahlen sagte
1971 bei viel information wird etwas
anderes knapp wo herrscht knappheit bei
der aufmerksamkeit
ein tag hat nur 24 stunden
einerseits haben wir also eine
exponentielle zunahme an information
andererseits ist unsere aufmerksamkeit
begrenzt aufmerksamkeit gewinnt man
durch informationen informationen die
die leute konsumieren wollen fake news
haben eine äußerst bedauerlich
sie setzten sich durch und machen viel
lernen so kommen sie in umlauf und
werden verbreitet das
informationszeitalter hat das phänomen
der fake news verstärkt die es seit
menschengedenken gibt es gibt eine
mischung zwischen ökonomischen faktoren
wo wir sagen können aufmerksamkeit ist
die ware mit der eigentlich gehandelt
wird und die frage wie man diese
aufmerksamkeit am besten auf sich zieht
das ist eine grell heidt eine
schrillheit teilweise auch eine
extremität der nachricht aber das könnte
man sagen das waren 1920 genauso auf der
straße wenn jemand geschrieben hat
weltkriegs ausbruch oder die russen
kommen das ist ja gar keine neue dynamik
die jetzt so wäre dass wir heute darüber
mehr reden müssten als 480 haben heute
sind sie vermehrt ein thema weil sie
offenbar weltweit willkommen in dem
soziale medien und andere ventile
benutzt werden um diese geschichten in
umlauf zu bringen
so gesehen hat es plötzlich eine
reichweite und eine geschwindigkeit die
wir vorher nicht gekannt haben die
reichweite und die geschwindigkeit
machen den unterschied
deshalb wird es heute so umfassend
diskutiert und dann müssen sie sich auch
bewusst sein es geht um geld
so gab es etwa zu den amerikanischen
wahlen zahlreiche angeht
michel studie viele dieser gefälschten
geschichten kamen aus mazedonien ein
paar junge männer produzierten diese
feld deuce
man muss sich bewusst sein sie
verdienten 3 147 dollar im monat
sie starteten zwei fake news sites und
erhöhten ihr einkommen auf 16.000 dollar
im monat
deshalb im wesentlichen weil sie den
werbekunden die aufmerksamkeit die
mediennutzer verkaufen was man im
informationszeitalter in bezug auf
soziale medien usw sehr gründlich
bedenken muss wenn sie glauben dass sie
als nutzer eine art kunde sind dann
überlegen sie noch einmal
sie sind kein kunde weil sie nicht dafür
zahlen jene die bezahlen sind die kunden
betrachten sie das ganze von diesem
gesichtspunkt das geschäft der sozialen
medien besteht darin durch informationen
die aufmerksamkeit der menschen
anzuziehen und diese aufmerksamkeit dann
an die werber zu verkaufen jeder online
user ist nicht kunde sondern produkt das
ist dass ich eine ganz wichtige
erkenntnis überhaupt über die
funktionsweise des internets das dann
immer etwas umsonst ist wie sozialer
netzwerke ist man nicht eigentlich der
linie das nutzt und ein mann ist auch
oder vorrangig auch der benutzte wenn
ich sie richtig verstanden habe
philosophen sind ja auch begriffs
schärfer versuchen doch noch mal
einzugrenzen was fake news sind wenn ich
jetzt zum beispiel sage die sternstunde
philosophie sind das weltweit populärste
philosophie format dann ist das
vielleicht richtig oder falsch ich weiß
es gar nicht ist das schon fake news
sind flunkereien oder scherzhafte
übertreibung fake news oder gibt es da
eine definitorischen bestimmung die
sagen das macht nix zu fuß wir haben
soeben ein buch über fake news
geschrieben
in diesem buch klassifizieren wir
verschiedene aussagen ob sie als fake
news gelten oder nicht zuoberst in der
scala zum ersten bereich gehören setzte
die klare fakten ausdrücken
hier ist ein glas wasser sie tragen eine
brille
sind die geprüften fakten und gleich
eine stufe weiter unten gibt es
fabrizierte fakten oder wenn sie wollen
manipulierte aussagen
sie sind nicht unbedingt falsch sie
könnten zugeschnitten sagen was ist
ihnen lieber 90% beschäftigungen oder
zehn prozent arbeitslosigkeit unter dem
strich ist es das gleiche es geht über
selektionen wie man die dinge
präsentiert selektion wie man etwas
präsentiert rosinenpicken oder gewisse
fakten unterschlagen und so weiter an
dritter stelle kommt das gericht
gerüchte können wahr oder falsch seien
dann haben sie das was harry frankfurt
bullshit nennt etwas das absichtlich
keinen unterschied zwischen wahrheit und
unwahrheit macht da geht es lügen die
grundsätzlich falsch sind und
schließlich haben sie fake news als
letzten punkt
die fake news in der regel ein
nischenprodukt das aber als echte
aktuelle news geschichte präsentiert
wird das macht sie speziell gefährlich
nicht weil zwangsläufig alles falsch ist
sondern weil es sich dabei um eine
vorgespielte realität handelt sie kommen
als ersatz realität daher
dadurch sind sie viel schwieriger zu
entlarven weil die gängigen kriterien
zur entlassung von behauptungen ganz
anders sind auch aus philosophischer
sicht ist das wirklich gift parasitäre
systeme die eigentlich aufsetzen auf
waren nachrichten und sich so geben
verkleiden und dann eine misch zone
gründen wie das genau funktioniert das
können wir uns jetzt in einem kleinen
einspieler mal am konkreten beispiel
ansehen
ein junge im syrischen bürgerkrieg
tödlich getroffen von heckenschützen
doch nein er lebt er rettet sogar noch
ein verängstigtes mädchen und wird so
zum helden
das video erreichte auf youtube ein
millionenpublikum und so weltweites
aufsehen
es ist definitiv in syrien aufgenommen
vermutlich an der bürger kriegsfront
unklar ist woher genau die schüsse und
der rauch kommen
doch die bilder sind weder aus syrien
noch aus dem krieg drehort war malta die
filmcrew wollte angeblich nur vor
kriegen wahrnimmt was ist echt was
inszeniert
auch bei videos der terror miliz
islamischer staat hegen fachleute 2 wir
können ausschließen dass diese bringen
während dieses videos tatsächlich
ermordet worden sind
gegen die costa concordia wirklich so
und wie kommt man falschen fotos auf die
spur
das mädchen ist nicht aus der ukraine
sondern aus australien
was tun mit leserkommentaren die sich
haargenau gleichen und was mit
verschwörungstheorien
ob über charlie hebdo oder darüber dass
der islamische staat angeblich von
amerika gesteuert werden wir haben jetzt
auch gesehen an diesen beispielen dass
das moralisch oder politisch gar nicht
so leicht zu verorten ist es gibt gute
fake news oder moralisch gut intention
ihres und schlechte das heißt regens an
sich ist noch gar kein term dem man
politisch verorten kann
nein nicht wirklich was man betonen muss
ist dass wir die üblichen kriterien nach
denen wir aussagen beurteilen
überschreiten wissenschaftliche aussagen
etwa werden als richtig oder falsch
eingestuft
vorausgesetzt man findet eine methode
mit jemand zeigen kann ob sie richtig
oder falsch sind
das wird hier überschritten weil die
auswahl an erfolgskriterien für fake
news meist anders sind ein
erfolgskriterium ist leute von etwas zu
überzeugen
ein politischer standpunkt eine
moralische überzeugung
eine religiöse neigung was immer sie
wollen sie nehmen im wesentlichen was
ist und sagen so ist es aber so sollte
es sein und dann bieten sie es so
zurecht darum geht es bei fonds im
wesentlichen die grenze wird
überschritten in der sich die
philosophie normalerweise bewegt oder
der gesunde menschenverstand namentlich
hier haben die dinge wie sie sind und da
wie sie sein sollten und fake news kann
die linie dazwischen verwischen
dieses phänomen hat ja auch technische
voraussetzung und es hat sehr viel damit
zu tun wir haben das gesehen film dass
man mittlerweile mit bildern die die
dominante form unserer wirklichkeit
erschließung medial sind eben alles
machen kann
das heißt es freut sich ein öffnet ihren
raum der simulation der gar nicht so
leicht zu unterscheiden ist ist das
eigentlich so dass wir auf einem weg in
ein zeitalter der skepsis sind in denen
wir wirklichkeit von fälschung aufgrund
der technischen voraussetzungen gar
nicht mehr unterscheiden können ja in
einem gewissen sinn nähern wir uns den
klassischen skeptizismus kania des aka
sie los die die katholische akademie
übernommen hatten wenn sie so wollen
dass man nämlich heute mit film machen
kann
mit photo weiter das geht in richtung
unter determiniert
dabei geht es im wesentlichen um das
problem dass es keine klare abgrenzung
gibt zwischen dem was ist und dem was
nicht ist oder und die frage wie wir
herausfinden können ob wir ein gehirn im
tank sind oder nicht erfahren um das
festzustellen
darum geht es wenn sie sich nämlich
diesen filmausschnitt anschauen ist es
schwer zu sagen ob er echt ist
ob er ein wirkliches ereignis
widerspiegelt es stellte sich heraus
dass ihr simuliert war
die normalen voraussetzungen dass wir
unsere sinne brauchen um zu entscheiden
ob etwas echt ist oder nicht werden
heute herausgefordert durch die
möglichkeiten der filmproduktion
man kann fummeln manipulieren mit
bildern filmausschnitten usw
so gesehen könnte man sagen dass der
antike skeptizismus dank der fake news
eine ehrenhafte rückkehr erlebt
das ist der punkt es gibt noch ein
anderes ereignis der philosophie das ist
der e card hessische dämon auch die
karts fragte sich ob unsere ganze welt
nicht eine simulation sein könnte die so
perfekt ist dass sie von der
wirklichkeit nicht zu unterscheiden wäre
aber die karte hat ja auch methoden
dafür freigelegt wie wir das
unterscheiden sind diese methoden heute
noch tragbar oder welche methoden
schlagen sie vor
das ist eine sehr gute frage wenn sie
kann ihr das nehmen und die cartoons
traktat über die menschliche natur oder
hilary putnam gehirn im tank das sind
alles philosophen die sich mit
skeptizismus auseinandergesetzt haben
wir alle beschäftigen uns auf die eine
oder andere art mit skeptizismus ihre
grundlage ist was man als globale unter
determiniert verzeichnet das heißt im
wesentlichen dass man bei keiner art von
wahrnehmung unterscheiden kann ob sie
simuliert oder real ist
darum geht es fake news basieren auf der
gleichen struktur descartes war aber
auch ein wissenschaftler
er beschäftigte sich mit optik deshalb
interessierte sich nicht für
metaphysischen skeptizismus ob es die
welt gibt oder nicht
ihn beschäftigte die frage ob man
methodologische alles bezweifeln und
trotzdem eine basis für unser
erkenntnisvermögen finden können
schließlich kam er zum schluss braucht
deinen verstand ist das heute überhaupt
noch ein weg ja teilweise ist das immer
noch ein weg den wir gehen können
um jetzt aber weiter zu kommen müssen
wir recherchieren wie auch journalisten
recherchieren wir arbeiten an gewissen
methoden mit denen man erkennt ob das
was wir wahrnehmen korrekt ist
sagen wir so was machen journalisten sie
nehmen die quellen mehr als eine sieht
regulieren die information versuchen aus
verschiedenen perspektiven zu bestätigen
ja um eine bestätigung oder widerlegung
falsifizieren zu erhalten in der
wissenschaft machen wir das gleiche wir
setzen ein experiment auf wir testen und
verifizieren ob es stimmt sagen wir es
so heute ist der druck auf den
journalismus viel größer wenn es darum
geht herauszufinden ob jene
informationen die man uns vor setzt war
sind eine enorme herausforderung da die
menge an informationen sorin sich ist
und das tempo so hoch ist das schwierig
das bedroht die grundlagen des schon
philosophisch interessant ist wenn sie
die wenigen institute anschauen die
journalistische ethik erforschen die
grundprinzipien und stärken von gutem
journalismus
sie arbeiten mit dem konzept
journalistische wahrheit
das bedeutet fakten so weit als möglich
nachvollziehen informationen regulieren
quellen prüfen und so weiter wenn sie
die zehn regeln über guten journalismus
nachlesen sind diese sehr nahe an dem
was in der wissenschaftsphilosophie im
grundkurs gelegt es ist also dass das
verfahren ein methodisches verfahren
eine rettung sein kann aber in dem was
sie sagen gibt es ja noch ein weiteres
paradox der journalismus selbst hat eine
finanzierungskrise und diese verfahren
sind sehr teuer würden sie dann sagen es
ist eine besonders ungünstige situation
weil die auf anforderung an journalist
muss weiter steigen und die
finanzierungsgrundlage weiter erodiert
ja da haben sie recht
das problem liegt in gewisser hinsicht
im informationszeitalter was man in der
wissenschaft nicht kennt ist das
information heute einen preis hat
sie trägt ein preisschild manche
informationen sind billig manche sind
extrem teuer
wissenschaftliche informationen sind in
der regel sehr teuer weil man testen
muss es braucht eine methode quellen
müssen überprüft werden man muss
systematisch vorgehen
das gleiche gilt für den journalismus
das bedeutet gute journalistische
produkte oder gute wissenschafts
berichte sind sehr teuer verglichen mit
fake news die man bloß produziert und in
umlauf bringt
hinzu kommt dass die wahrheit meist
nicht besonders laut ist wahrheit ist
was ist was wahr ist geht nicht
unbedingt viral und was viral geht ist
nicht zwingend war und da haben wir das
paradox wenn die realität ein maßstab
für aufmerksamkeit ist ist das erlangen
von aufmerksamkeit eine frage des geldes
so erhält information einen preis
deshalb könnte es ihnen nützen wenn sie
informationen in umlauf bringen die
nicht getestet wurden aber viel
aufmerksamkeit auf sich ziehen weil es
mehr zeit braucht wahrheit zu
produzieren die möglicherweise nie diese
aufmerksamkeit erhält könnte sein dass
die wahrheit sich nicht auszahlt
ökonomisch wenn ich sie richtig verstehe
auf eine finanzierungsgrundlage das
bringt mich auf einen zweiten punkt die
frage ist aber wer produziert diese
fällt muss und dafür gibt es
verschiedene erklärungsansätze man hat
große politische spieler oder agenten
die ganze starten
man hat ökonomische interessen wie zb pr
firmen und dann hat man kleine 16
jährige jungs oder mädchen die daraus
ein schnelles geschäft machen wo würden
sie sagen sind derzeit die stärksten
kräfte global in der produktion auch
diejenigen vor denen wir uns am meisten
acht nehmen müssen zuerst einmal scheint
mir wichtig mindestens drei gründe für
die produktion von fake news zu
unterscheiden also aus wie wir auch im
buch fake news beschreiben aus vergnügen
als toll unruhe stiften eine diskussion
vom zaun reißen dann um politisch
einfluss zu nehmen oder viel geld das
sind die drei gründe
natürlich können denn auch vermischt
werden aber ehrlicherweise muss man
sagen dass jene fake news mit dem bisher
größten einfluss in unterschiedlichen
größen und formen auf der politischen
bühne gestreut wurden
das ist schon schlimm genug in den
jahren 2013 14 15 16 17 hat das world
economic forum viel information im
internet als globale herausforderung
genau gleich bedeutend wie globale
gesundheit langzeit investitionen
migration klima und so weiter in diese
richtung gehen
deshalb gelten saic news als globale
herausforderung
sie sagen weil sie die weltpolitik
herausfordern
das heißt die demokratie wie wir sie in
der westlichen welt und anders erkennen
so gesehen kann man sagen fällt - kommen
von vielen unterschiedlichen orten und
es gibt vielleicht unterschiedliche
anreize aber auf lange sicht vergiften
und zerstören sie die demokratien weil
man durch sie langfristig in einer
sogenannten post faktischen demokratie
enden könnte eine post faktische
demokratie oder eine demokratie in einem
post faktischen start ist eine
demokratie in der opportune geschichten
die auf fehlinformationen beruhen die
basis für gesetzgebung debatte und
politische interaktionen werden
das ist eine gefährliche situation
zwei fragen glauben sie dass wir schon
an diesem punkt sind und zweitens ist es
denn wirklich so dass eine demokratie
nur auf fakten beruhen kann oder muss
sie nicht in gleicher weise auch auf
fiktion und träumen beruhen und dass die
fakten basiert hat von der demokratie
vielleicht gar nicht so stark ist wie
sie behaupten eine sehr gute frage
in unserem buch stets e-post faktische
demokratie am einen ende der skala
am anderen ist was man eine technokratie
nennen könnte wo alles auf bloßen fakten
was wir behaupten nicht dass es einmal
ein goldenes zeitalter gegeben hat in
dem journalisten bürger wissenschaftler
und politiker die wahrheit sagten und
nichts als die wahrheit
wahrscheinlich hat es das nie gegeben
betrachten sie diese beiden beispiele
also als grenzwerte einer skala auf dem
man sich vor und rückwärts bewegt je
nach zeitgeist finanzieller situation im
moment bewegen wir uns auf etwas zu dass
ein wenig einen post faktischen stadium
das könnte aber auch wieder umgedreht
werden mit hilfe von journalismus
wissenschaft und so weiter eine
demokratie besteht zu einem teil aus
fakten die andere teil ist ideologie
visionen oder wie immer sie das nennen
wollen
die mischung dieser beiden bestandteile
ergibt eine funktionierende demokratie
wir wissen und wir wissen es seit der
aufklärung aus der unsere prinzipien der
demokratie stammen das informationen
helfen bessere entscheide zu fällen und
im informationszeitalter
leider fehlen die leute nicht unbedingt
bessere entscheide je mehr man sie mit
informationen überhäuft kanton die
übrigen philosophen der aufklärung taten
sich sehr schwer damit weil sie sich ins
dunkle mittelalter zurückversetzt sehen
aus dem sie versuchten herauszukommen
gerade in dem sie wissen und
informationen heraufbeschworen haben
natürlich sehr interessant was sie sagen
weil sie sagen das was die aufklärung
eigentlich produzieren wollte
meinungsfreiheit information schlägt
jetzt gleichsam zurück und wird
unkontrollierbar eine frage die mich
interessiert ist es so viel energie in
dem was sie sagen es ist auch so viel
agenda
sie waren lange zeit ein akademiker der
sich mit sehr schwierigen komplizierten
logischen und mathematischen schluss
problemen beschäftigt hat seit 23 jahren
sind sie in babbel starting center und
organisieren studien zu diesem phänomen
und sind auch als public intellectuals
unterwegs ist das für sie selbst ein
weckruf für die philosophie dass man
sagt jetzt können wir nicht länger
schweigen wir müssen an dieses probleme
an
ich habe einen 17 jährigen sohn
ich hätte bis ans lebensende mit meinen
konvergenz theorie man in dynamischer
systemischer logik und formaler lern
theorie weitermachen können aber vor ein
paar jahren als ich den dänischen elite
forschungspreis erhalten habe kam ein
sohn und stellte mir zwei fragen er
sagte hab ich möchte wissen was machst
du eigentlich
das ist eine gute frage aber die zweite
frage war noch besser
deshalb ist es wichtig weshalb ist es
wichtig da konnten sie das damals nicht
erklären und können ihm das jetzt besser
als ich es früher konnte weil ich
eigentlich der nächsten generation eine
welt übergeben möchte die in einem
deren zustand ist als jene die ich von
meinen eltern erhalten habe das nennt
man fortschritt ich finde im moment ist
das schwer zu erkennen
also versuche ich die methode der
wissenschaft zu nutzen
wir erhielten die finanzierung für den
aufbau des zentrums für informations-
und model studies von der karlsberg
stiftungen bei der übergabe sagte deren
vorsitzender fleming wesen bacher dieses
zentrum sei ein zentrales beispiel für
die soziale verantwortung der
wissenschaft
das sind wir
es gibt soziale
unternehmensverantwortung man kann aber
auch von sozialer wissenschafts
verantwortung sprechen
die grundidee wir nutzen wissenschaft um
uns für die globalen herausforderungen
zu engagieren
damit diese welt ein besserer ort wird
auch dank die wissenschaft nicht dass
wir das bisher verpasst hätten aber mit
der jetzigen agenda hat diese idee viel
mehr gewicht durch die tatsache dass die
wahrheit etwas in frage gestellt ist
wurde sie viel präsenter das ist der
beitrag oder worin besteht der beitrag
man könnte ja sagen dass sollten
soziologen machen
das sollten taten analysten machen was
ist der beitrag der philosophie in
spezieller weise der leisten kann und
haben sie das gefühl dass die
philosophen überhaupt begriffen haben
dass ihr diesen beitrag leisten müssen
als schütten als ich sollte nicht
extrapolieren was jeder philosoph zu
denken oder zu tun hat ich bin im grunde
ein logischer und sage büros hier ist
eine werkzeugkiste voller logik kann die
logik geht es vor allem um prinzipien
die informationsverarbeitung manchmal
gut manchmal schlecht und um die
strukturen und die dynamiken der
informationsprozesse das ist
gewissermaßen um was es bei die logik
wird
lasst uns also diese werkzeuge nehmen um
phänomene des realen lebens zu studieren
von den vier - bis hin zu den
informations wasserfällen um
herauszufinden was es aus der
perspektive der information für
praktische probleme gibt und dann
schauen ob es präventive maßnahmen gibt
wenn wir die mathematischen modelle
einmal eingesetzt haben
im norden sind bei der therapie
sozusagen als die ein arzt der eine
krankheit behandelt ja in gewissem sinne
dazu ein lustiges beispiel es gibt den
begriff pluralistische ignoranz das ist
ein phänomen aus der sozialpsychologie
das konzept dahinter
sie glauben etwas nicht denken aber
fälschlicherweise dass ihre kollegen das
gegenteil von ihnen glaubt das heißt im
kollektiv unterstützt man normen die man
als individuum zurückweisen würde
das ergibt ein gemeinsames vorgehen das
hat man in vielen fällen von risiko
verhalten bei kindern und jugendlichen
nachgewiesen bei trinkt oder party
verhalten aber auch beim cyber morgen
wir machten eine große studie zu diesem
thema und betraten 1515 jährige zu ihrer
eigenen haltung betreffend cybermobbing
und fragten auch was sie glaubten was
ihre kollegen darüber denken
nun kommt es sie selber mochten es nicht
eine mehrheit fand cybermobbing
inakzeptabel aber fälschlicherweise
glauben sie dass ihre klassenkameraden
und vor allem ihre freunde darüber viel
positiver denken als sie selber das
wusste man schon seit einiger zeit von
anderen risikoverhalten wie trinken und
so weiter aber jetzt haben wir gezeigt
dass es auch beim cybermobbing so ist
nun ist die frage was macht man damit
eine möglichkeit ist dass man den
mahnfinger nimmt unser halb du darfst am
wochenende nicht trinken oder du darfst
nicht cybermobbing
das funktioniert nicht aber
untersuchungen in den usa haben gezeigt
dass bei experimenten wo eine gruppe den
mahnfinger erhält das nicht während man
bei der zweiten gruppe nicht tut und der
dritten gruppe erklärt man die
praktischen hintergründe der
pluralistischen lieben runs weil bereits
das verstehen dieses phänomens eine
präventive wirkung haben könnte damit
hat man ein sehr gutes argument in der
hand für die erforschung dieser dinge
weil das verstehen und isolieren und
ihre praktischen hintergründe dieses
problems tatsächlich schon präventiv
wirken können
das gleiche gilt für fake news und
anderes es ist ja eine sache die man
sich so nicht überlegt es ist unsere
glauben und das was wir glauben
meinungen haben ist nicht nur in
auseinandersetzung mit der realität
sondern wird ganz stark davon weiß was
wir glauben dass andere leute glauben
und dafür haben wir jetzt einen kleinen
beispiel wie das insbesondere in
digitalen systemen und netzwerken
funktioniert wie dieser effekt
funktioniert der mechanismus am beispiel
eines klima skeptikern was seine meinung
widerlegt blendet der tendenziell aus
was ihn bestätigt nimmt er stärker war
so wird seine überzeugung immer noch
stärker der konfirmation bayers so heißt
dieser mechanismus ist eine
psychologische bestätigungs falle die
allen menschen droht im internet wird
dieser psychologische effekt verstärkt
firmen wie facebook und google merken
was uns interessiert und gefällt und sie
geben uns mehr davon
der klimaskeptiker sieht immer mehr
nachrichten die seiner überzeugung
entsprechen andere argumente dringen
kaum noch durch eine filter blase
entsteht ein raum in dem wir immer nur
die gleichen stimmen hören denn was uns
in unserer ansicht bestärkt teilen wir
mit freunden und gleichgesinnten
so entsteht ein kreislauf der
bestätigung
ihr institut ist das weltweit erste und
einzige süd für babbel studies für
filter blasen studien und filter klassen
sind wenn nicht dem film folge räume in
denen gleichgesinnte gleichgesinnte
erfahren damit gefüttert werden und sich
weiter verengen und bestätigen ist das
eine definition von einer filter blase
filter blasen nach dem konzept von eli
pariser sind was sie hier gezeigt haben
väter blasen sind aber nur eines von
vielen verschiedenen blasen phänomenen
die wir am zentrum für information und
babbel studies untersuchen
unsere grundidee kommt aus der ökonomie
nämlich dass man merkte überhitzen kader
systematisch zu preisen gehandelt werden
die weit über ihren vernünftigen wert
liegen spricht man von einer blase zb
eine immobilienblase immobilienblasen
aktien finanzprodukte wie derivate und
so weiter betrachten sie es so man kann
auch kühlte überhitzen die keinen
monetären wert haben status einfluss
macht man kann sogar von wissenschafts
blasen sprechen man für disziplinen
erhalten große finanzielle unterstützung
oder aufmerksamkeit viele andere nicht
sogar mobbing blasen wo leute gar nichts
getan haben aber online ist die
wahrnehmung sie hätten etwas getan
damit ist das mobbing ziel schon
erreicht oder news blasen wo
nebensächlich ihre nachrichten plötzlich
viel aufmerksamkeit erhalten wie zum
beispiel gab es diese fake news dass
angela merkel quasi die leitung des zdf
innehabe die deutsche fernseh
gesellschaft etwas nicht stimmte aber
viel aufmerksamkeit erregte so kann man
andere werte als geldwerte überhitzen
und das spannende daran ist der online
markt etwa ist selektiv
es wird viel gehandelt meinungen likes
kommentare und service es gibt
zahlreiche zahlungsmittel da draußen
das berühmteste ist dass facebook like
ist eine möglichkeit in seiner meinung
zu investieren wenn sie nun in ihrer
meinung investieren und ich nicht so
aufgeklärt bin wie sie denke ich
vielleicht hier könnte recht haben
statt selber zu testen maike ich das was
sie leiten weil wir gleich denken oder
die gleichen ansichten teilen und
plötzlich haben wir eine situation in
der alle nach links gehen sogar wenn die
rechte idee völlig richtig ist und dann
kann man echo kammern verstärken und
polarisieren und sie haben auch
kognitive des sommers wenn wir eine
information finden die für uns nicht
stimmt neigen wir dazu sie zu ignorieren
ich hab mal ein beispiel viele
informationen vielleicht die sie nicht
ignorieren aber die man doch erwägen
könnte 0,1 prozent des traffics im
internet gehen über politische inhalte
zehn prozent gehen über pornographie ist
fake news als thema in den nachrichten
vielleicht selbst ein filter phänomen
einblasen kilometer nehmen wir das nicht
gleich zu wichtig wir wissen es noch
nicht
ich glaube das stimmt sie haben absolut
recht
eine studie von 2009 stellte fest dass
es bei 0,1 prozent des gesamten internet
austausch um politische diskussionen
ging zehn prozent drehte sich um
pornografie
das ist bei weitem das größte feld für
online informationen florieren vor allem
jetzt oder sie florieren erst seit
absolut und es ist ein großes thema
weshalb noch einmal wie das world
economic forum sagte es wird heute als
globale herausforderung gesehen
das internet ist sehr anpassungsfähig
und es ist auch organisch deshalb ist es
etwas schwierig vorauszusagen welchen
einfluss haben
könnte und ob es bloß ein
vorübergehendes phänomen ist aber ich
glaube man kann sagen dass die wahrheit
bis jetzt eine sehr gute begleiterin da
wir würden nicht hier sitzen und diese
diskussion führen gäbe es nicht etwas
das man wahr oder unwahr nennen kann man
könnte nicht einmal diese kameras
benutzen mit fake news als einziger
basis würden sie wahrscheinlich nicht
funktionieren wahrheit war uns also
nützlich bis jetzt und wahrscheinlich
wird es auch in zukunft so sein ist aber
schauen sie facebook startete 2004
jetzt haben wir 2017 wir haben also 13
jahre erfahrung mit dieser art von
plattform mit zwei milliarden produkten
haben eine sehr beschränkte erfahrung
mit dem informationszeitalter
wir sind alle teil dieses sozial
technischen experiments
mehr noch während wir hier am tisch
sitzen kommt die hälfte dessen was wir
ausdrücken weder aus meinem noch aus
ihrem mund es ist dass ich sie lese und
sie lesen nicht
sie steigen auf diesen vorschlag an ich
fahre weiter und damit will ich sagen
indem wir einander in die augen schauen
legen wir fest was unseres erachtens
allgemeinwissen heißt so funktioniert
dialog in dem wir uns voneinander
abheben wie wir uns aufeinander
einstellen
laufend lesen wir uns gegenseitig vor 13
jahren haben wir eine plattform erhalten
um diese art von dialog zu simulieren
wo wir so sprechen müssen nun kann es
sie nicht mehr sehen und die zuschauer
können mich nicht sehen
die frage ist ihr aufrichtig bei dem was
er sagt und sobald ich das mache die
reaktion a man liest sich gegenseitig
die ganze zeit diese voraussetzungen
haben es schwierig online das heißt die
möglichkeit ist größer dass es zu
fehlern kommt es gibt eine these
und das gefällt mir sehr was sie sagen
weil das sehr interessante die sagt der
buchdruck hat unsere ganze zivilisation
die stabilisiert und haben etwa 250
jahre gebraucht um verfahren und
kriterien zu entwickeln um mit dieser
informationsflut umzugehen
sie sagt dass selbst das internet
30 jahre alt diese sozialen netzwerke
keine zwanzig haben wir weitere 250
jahre bei man könnte ja sagen wenn wir
es nicht selbst sehr stark sehr schnell
erziehen
dann verlieren wir die grundlagen
unserer modernen gesellschaft es ist
definitiv so wir könnten in sehr große
schwierigkeiten geraten wenn wir uns
nicht selber erziehen
aus den vielen informationen kann man
aber auch viele einsichten gewinnen
dabei stellt sich die frage wie wir sie
richtig pflücken
das ist eine unserer herausforderungen
es wird viel über
informationsübermittlung geforscht und
vieles davon ist sehr wertvoll
wir wollen herausfinden ob man ein
gleichgewicht finden kann in welchen die
gute information überlebt das ist im
moment nämlich nicht der fall
ein weiterer interessanter aspekt den
wir am zentrum für informations- und
bobbys untersuchen sind die finanzmärkte
und der handel mit zero bonds die
insbesondere in den usa in hohem maß
dereguliert ist das gründete auf die
hypothese der markteffizienz nämlich
dass ein deregulierter markt dazu führt
dass die guten finanzprodukte überleben
und die schlechten ausgemustert werden
weil der markt effizienter ist als
natürliche qualitätskontrolle gleichsam
natürliche qualitätskontrolle durch
einen effizienten markt mit der zeit hat
man herausgefunden dass viele schlechte
wertpapiere recht lange überlebt haben
deshalb haben sie in den usa im subprime
krise also schlechte papiere konnten
lange zeit überleben und wurden
möglicherweise künstlich aufgeblasen
sogar einen greens bahn musste
eingestehen dass in diesem fall die
hypothese der markteffizienz
möglicherweise nicht stimmt weil
schlechte papiere lange zeit überlegen
konnten das gleiche gilt für einen
deregulierten informationsmarkt mana
passieren dass es keine garantie für
einen effizienten informationsmarkt gibt
wenn man ihn nicht irgendwie reguliert
und ich die leute dazu erzählt ihn
richtig zu benutzen
genau gleich so dass die gute
information schließlich überlebt die
schlechte nicht die frage ist was tun
regulierungen sind ein teil ausbildung
ein anderer
eine neue studie in den usa gesagt man
müsste die neugier für wissenschaft
fördern wenn wir eine information
erhalten sollte uns nicht interessieren
ob wir damit einverstanden sind oder
nicht sondern woher sie kommt was sind
die quellen gibt es mögliche absitzen
dahinter
und das tolle an neugier ist neugier ist
meist unvoreingenommen ich bin einfach
neugierig wenn wir also eine
informations neugier erzeugen können ob
für die informations auswahl fürs
herauspicken usw
wird das ein teil des ausbildungs
portfolios für uns menschen des
informationszeitalters es ist ja auch
interessant dass sie sagen wir sprechen
immer davon dass jeder mittlerweile ein
journalist ist dass jeder seine meinung
äußern darf aber wenn ich sie richtig
verstanden habe heißt wer jeder
journalist ist muss auch jeder die
tugenden des journalisten verinnerlichen
und wissen wie man fakten überprüft das
heißt es ist nicht nur eine
einbahnstraße der äußerung sondern auch
eine der überprüfung und das ist etwas
was viele leute glaube ich noch gar
nicht begreifen jeder denkt er ist ein
journalist aber nicht jeder hat die
fähigkeiten die die jugend standard des
journalismus selbst einzulösen
das stimmt vollkommen sein kann sagen
dass jeder der ein online profil besitzt
in gewissem sinn ein reporter damit
macht facebook sein geld sie berichten
über ihre freunde über ihre erlebnisse
und so weiter aber sie sind kein
überprüfte händler schon wenn sie sich
bei facebook instagram oder wo auch
immer eintragen unterschreiben sie auch
deren community standards
das heißt sie dürfen niemanden morgen
sie dürfen nicht absichtlich falsche
dinge behaupten oder doch dagegen gibt
es glaube ich keine rede
aber es gibt gewisse community standards
die man befolgen sollte wenn man die
plattform benutzen wird aber die leute
klicken das einfach weg und tragen sich
ein ohne darüber nachzudenken was ich
damit sagen will wir versuchen unsere
produkte zu
studieren unsere journalisten und jetzt
kann jeder sich online selber
journalisten sind
es ist aber ein äußerst unfair
informationsmarkt weil manche
journalisten regulierter sind als andere
wolf rahmen kann im schweizer fernsehen
sagen was immer er will
das heißt sie sind reguliert durch
maßstäbe betreffend gutem journalismus
und wahrscheinlich tragen sie sogar
verantwortung gegenüber dem medium das
nicht alles ausstrahlen darf sie kämpfen
also gegen des beraters die keine
solchen regeln haben und weil die nicht
reguliert sind können sie informationen
in umlauf bringen die vermutlich breite
geschrieben gesehen und gehört werden
als sternstunde philosophie die bei
allem respekt nicht den gleichen
einfluss hat wenn jetzt alle behaupten
ich bin wissenschaftler ich habe
experiment gemacht und ich kann
schneller als licht geschwindigkeit
fliegen dann bin ich nicht dann die
standards dieser community gebunden aber
ich habe viel aufmerksamkeit weil es
eine große these ist eine sache ist ja
interessant
sie sagten es gibt die idee dass der
markt sich selbst reguliert dass es im
geld wert so das ist eine information so
und es gibt natürlich viele menschen die
für freie rede für free speech
argumentieren die sagen die öffentlichen
medien sind selbst eine filter blase
weil sie nämlich regulieren
meine frage an sie ist filter blase ein
normatives konzept gibt es auch gute
blasen die wir unterstützen sollten
eine sehr gute frage unser zentrum gibt
es erst seit zwei jahren wir behaupten
nicht dass wir schon auf alles eine
antwort haben es einmal untersuchen wir
die praktischen grundlagen von
verschiedenen blasen phänomenen
man könnte sich aber vorstellen dass es
gewisse gutartige blasen gibt
man könnte auch von günstiger
aufmerksamkeits zuteilung sprechen wie
etwa die agenda 2030 die uno oder die
globalen top herausforderungen des wef
das dürfte nicht falsch sein wenn man
die aufmerksamkeit fürs klima für
migration gesundheit und so weiter über
stimuliert damit dieser ort ein besserer
ort für uns menschen wird den wir uns
teilen
so gesehen könnte es vorausgesetzt wir
haben einheitliche ziele gelegentlich
vielleicht eine gute idee
zielen zu mehr beachtung zu verhelfen
und die leute so dazu zu bringen das
richtige zu tun
für sich selber und für den rest gilt
was ihre intuition als philosoph sollten
wir solche künstlich geschaffenen
wohlmeinenden blasen unterstützen oder
sollten wir hart sein und sagen nein es
geht nur um die wahrheit es geht nicht
um die effekte das ist eine tiefgründige
frage ist nehmen wir
physiknobelpreisträger steven weinberg
sagte es aber sehr schön wir alle sind
irgendwie realisten wie alle schnüffeln
nach der wahrheit wenn wir nicht diesen
sicheren wert suchen gibt es nichts zu
schnüffeln
das heißt nicht dass wahrheit eine
einfache sache ist
manchmal sagt sie auch nicht genau was
meint manchmal stellt man einfach die
falschen fragen an die welt und sie
weigert sich und seine antwort zu geben
und manchmal sind diese fangen und so
weiter aber ich glaube fairerweise muss
man eingestehen ich habe vorhin darauf
angespielt dass sogar die wissenschaft
zwar nach wahrheit sucht gleichzeitig
müssen wir uns aber bewusst sein dass
wir von allen möglichen dingen
beeinflusst werden von finanzierungs
agenturen bis zur kommerziellen
interessen wie die wissenschaft auf sich
trug genau
und da gibt es das alles aber bis jetzt
sind wir immer noch eine art auf diesem
planeten und wie viele andere arten
ich gehe davon aus dass das erhalten der
art für weitere generationen immer noch
etwas ist das wir wollen
wenn wir aber auf diesem weg weitergehen
fordern wir uns vielleicht etwas zu
sehen
deshalb treffen wir also nicht einfach
die wahl deshalb nutzen wir nicht im
mittel und methoden die wissenschaft um
sicherzustellen dass die nächste
generation eine welt hatte auf der man
leben kann und dass es für eine weile
noch so weiter geht ist die anerkennung
der tatsache dass es etwas gibt das
wahrheit und etwas das falschheit heißt
und mittendrin müssen unsere visionen
und ideologien in dieser
sie zierten gleichung zum schluss kommen
dass menschsein bedeutet dass man
verantwortung trägt für sich und für
seine familie haben so schön gesagt es
geht darum dass man ein mensch ist ich
kann sie jetzt hier anfassen sie sind
mein dialogpartner sie sind wirklich
es ist nun gerade im netz so das haben
sie gesagt dass dieser konkrete
versicherungs möglichkeit fehlt und das
hat auch sehr viel mit den blasenbildung
zu tun weil nämlich viel unserer
gesprächspartner gar keine menschen sind
in diesen blasen und auch dazu schauen
wir uns mal kurz einen film an
so funktioniert's ist ein social dort
auf einen bestimmten herrscht
programmiert zum beispiel wahlen findet
der einschlägige beiträge teils auch
fake news liegt diese und teilt diese
dazu kann er vorgefertigte nachrichten
beliebig oft und rund um die uhr posten
dabei kommt der bot meist nicht einzeln
sondern tausendfach zum einsatz
durch solche bot armeen bekommen
einzelne post innert sekunden unzählige
lights und weil solche scheinbar
beliebten beiträge bevorzugt angezeigt
werden kann dass die stimmung verändern
und eine debatte verfälschen
social bots mischt nachweislich bei den
letzten großen abstimmungen wird vor
allem bei den us-wahlen letzten herbst
während der tv duelle stammte laut
oxford university
jeder vierte treat für clinton von einem
wort für trump gar jeder dritte also wir
können sehen wenn andere menschen
glauben dass sie eine meinung haben dann
beeinflusst uns dass das sind keine
menschen die etwas glauben meine ganz
wohlmeinende anti blasen frage wäre es
werden landminen geächtet es werden
gewisse medikamente geächtet warum sagt
man nicht einfach wir ächten social
spots soziale bots sind in erster linie
eine algorithmische möglichkeit man kann
sie auslöst es geht darum dass es
möglich ist computerprogramme zu
erstellen die sich so verhalten
grundsätzlich ist ihr zweck die
öffentliche meinung zu beeinflussen
aus philosophischer sicht ist das
irgendwie spannend weil wenn sie die
ecken ist theorie ganz allgemein
betrachten
in den letzten jahrhunderten hat sich
die erkenntnistheorie stark mit dem
individuum befasst die einzelnen was ihr
wissen und glauben kann und so weiter
heute fragt man das kommt vor allem aus
der sozialpsychologie was menschen
machen wenn sie nicht selber mehr
informationen finden können
man neigt dazu zu schauen was die
nächste umgebung über dies und das denkt
und übernimmt es das nennt man den
sozialen beweis dass zu tun kann sie
vernünftig sein denn so kann man die
erfahrungen von anderen nutzen und man
wird gescheiter durch die kollektive
intelligenz aber wenn gott in spe sind
haben wir eine völlig andere situation
es sind eigentlich nur programme die
einen fingerabdruck produzieren bei dem
man nicht mehr unterscheiden kann ob es
nun ein menschlicher fingerabdruck ist
oder ein bot und viele pots haben die
fähigkeit starke soziale beweise zu
kreieren
obwohl niemand dahinter steht so gesehen
kann man auf
in verschiedene arten getäuscht werden
natürlich könnte man das auch positiv
nutzen
angenommen wir nutzen watts auf umfragen
zu stimulieren von denen wir denken dass
sie wichtig sind
aber das setzt eine politische oder
ideologische globale diskussion über
herausforderungen voraus die gemeinsam
angegangen werden sollen es gibt keine
möglichkeit bot im internet zu
regulieren oder sie zu verbannen
das wird nicht geschehen aber glauben
sie nicht dass es ein politisches
manöver wäre zu sagen ich der
präsidentschaftskandidat der partei iks
verspreche meinen wählern keine bots von
mir im netz
klar einige parteien können was machen
was ist aber mit den parteisoldaten die
nicht zur partei gehören aber glauben
was diese sagen ist richtig oder wie
auch immer ich meine damit jede partei
kann das sagen und sie können damit
wahrscheinlich ihre wählerstimmen
stärken aber da könnten viele andere
interessen involviert seien weiter gehen
als die politische ideologie
deshalb glaube ich dass das
wahrscheinlich etwas schwierig und
natürlich führt das zurück zum thema mit
denen wir angefangen haben können wir
sagen auch die signale die erkennbaren
öffentlichen signale aus dem internet
echt sind im sinn von repräsentativ für
das was die leute denken oder sprechen
wir eher nicht über das was sie denken
sondern über ihre unmittelbare reaktion
oder ist es von bots generiert oder
irgendetwas das gehört zu den großen
herausforderungen des lebens im
informationszeitalter die tatsächliche
meinung von jenen die im internet
operieren ist schwierig zu ermitteln
als erstes sind sie aufrichtig in dem
was sie sagen und dann am anderen ende
gibt es sie wirklich oder sprechen wir
über bot verhalten usw
noch einmal wir wissen nicht genau wie
sie arbeiten aber wir wissen es gab viel
bock generierte aufmerksamkeit für
politische kandidaten oder programme usw
und dass sie eine rolle spielen die
frage ist gibt es eine möglichkeit der
regulierung um da herauszukommen
und da sehe ich kaum eine chance es gibt
ja einen schönen satz von immer erkannt
was aufklärung ist der ausgang aus
seiner selbstverschuldeten unmögliche
unmündigkeit wir versuchen dass hier was
sind denn sie sprachen von ihrem sohn
die drei sachen die sie ihm als
netzsurfer sagen drei konkreten tipps
die sie allen vielleicht weitergeben
wollen so wird mündigkeit gefördert wann
immer ich ein like oder einen kommentar
sitze habe ich meine eigene unabhängige
begründung dafür das was ich sage
korrekt ist
vertrete ich mein eigenes argument oder
wiederhole ich ohne es getestet zu haben
das argument eines anderen
anders gesagt stimmt ein argument für
mich bin ich überzeugt dass ein argument
das für mich stimmt auch wie jemand
anderes stimmt gebe ich meine eigene
meinung weiter
das ist etwas dass ein individuum
manchmal noch kontrollieren kann
das ist punkt 1.2 was sehr wichtig ist
bin ich sicher dass ich nicht als opfer
von pluralistischer ignoranz bin im sinn
von habe ich eine realistische
vorstellung davon was andere leute
glauben oder ist es mir nicht klar
wenn mein bild systematisch betrübt ist
sollte ich meine meinung hier vielleicht
nicht einbringen
schließlich nummer drei es spielt keine
rolle ob sie glauben was zählt sind die
annahmen weshalb sie glauben und es ist
auch nicht wichtig dass sie glauben und
ich nicht was interessiert sind die
voraussetzungen weshalb sie glauben und
ich nicht der grund beim vergleichen der
voraussetzungen verhelfen uns die
unterschiede zur faktische aufklärung
einverstanden oder nicht gleicher
meinung zu sein ist nicht spannend
spannend ist zu verstehen weshalb hier
gleicher meinung sind oder eben nicht
das bringt erkenntnis ich habe noch
einen vierten vorschlag für sie ich war
die letzten vier wochen auf einer hütte
in finnland und hatte gar kein netz ist
das nicht auch eine option nummer 4
bleibt vom netzwerk sicher sehen sie den
stecker wie eine gewisse zeit
der grund unsere aufmerksamkeit ist
bestrebt jedes nachtessen mit freunden
sobald einer sich hinsetzt und sein
smartphone konsultiert vergiftet ihr die
stimmung was sie damit sagen will
es könnte zuträglich sein für
zwischenmenschliche beziehungen einfach
zu sitzen und zu sprechen ich habe für
sie noch eine blase wenn ich gerne mit
ihnen sprechen würde
die mutter aller blasen die sieht so aus
was fällt ihnen zu dieser blase ein
das ist die gutartig sste und
komplizierteste blase die wir bisher
kennen und wissen sie was wir können aus
ihr entkommen
aber es ist auch eine blase die nur das
rein lässt was sie soll das ist eine
abschottung und sie ist sehr angenehm
aber diese blase dauert neun monate und
dann sehen sie die melden diese welt
vermittelt ihnen eindrücke die sehr
anders sind als wenn sie also sicher das
was immer in der blase ist genügend
anpassungsfähig ist um mit dieser art
von eindrücken die es erhalten wird klar
zu kommen
bis jetzt sind wir über die runden
gekommen aber seien sie sich bewusst wir
sind seit 250 tausend jahren menschen
die welt ist milliarden von jahren alt
so gesehen sind wir gerade mal ein komma
und was wir das zeitalter der aufklärung
nennen ist nicht einmal ein komma es ist
als ob wir beginnen einen teil eines
buchstabens zu zeichnen
man muss festhalten uns gibt es erst
seit sehr kurzer zeit wenn wir darauf
bestehen dass es uns noch längere zeit
gibt müssen wir sicherstellen dass die
informationen die zwischen
gießen mehr oder weniger wahr sind oder
wenigstens zum ziel haben es zu sagen
weil wir sonst scheitern
weshalb uns also ohne not dumm verhalten
nehme den imperativ mit rauf aus der
blase sucht die widerstände sucht die
wahrheit das ist das was wir alle tun
müssen wir ja gar nicht hier und ich
danke ihnen dass sie uns heute die
ersten schritte dazu gezeigt haben
vielen dank
hendricks
[Musik]